hey by talking about the question of
human sacrifice something that was of
riveting interest to the Spaniards Salif
when they came into the world and less
so to other people because the
concentration of human sacrifice in
quantity and in lurid Niseko although
you have very clear evidence of human
sacrifice
among the Incas in South America and
Peru and somewhat more equivocal
evidence of human sacrifice for for
Native American groups in North America
the words the the phrase human sacrifice
is profoundly ambiguous to some degree
it is associated with as a it appears to
be a residual category deliberate taking
of human life that is not in the context
of crime and not in the context of
warfare and not in the context of
legitimate conflict such as football
you know deliberate a few in life and
other than these contexts tends to be
defined as human sacrifice however there
are very different functions that
sacrifice of any sort can be seen to to
fulfill the one that is most commonly
assumed is that a sacrifice relates to
God's and relates to either a either
placating an angry God or you know
seeking to retain the favors of a
benevolent God that might forget about
you if you didn't spill little blood in
this direction from time to time so
that's the sort of sacrifice to the gods
then there is expiatory sacrifice that
is to sacrifice in order to choose to
repay a debt or a or redress of sin that
is very specific it's not general it
isn't a sacrifice to cause asunder eyes
or the the gods to be friendly in
general or rain to come but rather it is
to expiate something so that when
Agamemnon offends the gods and they
withdraw the winds from the mckeon fleet
and the Iliad he sacrifices his daughter
Iphigenia
why he didn't sacrifice himself which
would have been a much cooler thing to
do
no one knows but but so you have at
serve expiatory sacrifice then you have
purificatory sacrifice where you have a
killing that is designed to create
a pure situation sometimes having to do
with using the the blood or other
aspects of the killed being in a
purificatory process the ancient
Israelite notion of killing a red heifer
and using and burning parts of the
animal and using the ashes for
purification rituals as part of the
temple rituals ordained in Torah that
would be one example but there are
others for example among the the
Hittites there are a fair number of
texts that talk about dividing
sacrificed animals including humans
where you you take the animal
particularly puppies actually not
full-grown dogs but puppies and you you
cut it in half and you place one half
over here and one half over there and
then you you go between them and that
that cleanses you or your army or
whatever it is you want cleanse and
while it is mostly done with puppies
it's also with other animals and it can
be done with people so that you can take
a pretty young actually I don't know
whether it's lengthwise I've always
assumed that it was you know front half
back half but I good question
if you can drum up some evidence on it
you can report to the class it's not not
very clear to me so when we have the the
sacrifices in oh and then a fourth one
is a funeral sacrifice that is we're
either with an explicit doctrine of
providing accompaniment for the deceased
in the afterworld or you know
symbolically to to do something to
recognize the death of a of an important
person either members of that person's
family usually his wife or part of his
household retinue or members of an armed
band that are dedicated to him will be
killed in order to to make a full
funeral sacrifice in the Iliad to go
back to that as a well-known text when
Patroclus has his funeral Achilles goes
out and captures twelve Trojan warriors
and sacrifices them on the funeral pyre
of Patroclus and throws in some dogs for
good measure and it's interesting that
the you know when people think about the
Iliad they often will comment on the
sacrifice of Iphigenia the daughter of
the King Agamemnon and then sort of
gloss over with it barely noticing the
funeral sacrifice of these twelve Trojan
labs because there's something
you know spiritually engaging about
Agamemnon and his daughter analogous
obviously to what is engaging about the
story of Abraham and his son whereas a
straightforward slaughter for an utterly
pointless accompaniment of a funeral
seemingly pointless seems to leave you
mess to talk about and this of course is
part of the whole problem of dealing
with this historically is that people
bring so much baggage to bear in
thinking about deliberate killing it has
to do with issues of what is crime what
is what is it that makes killing and
warfare legitimate what is it that makes
the blood the life of captives in say
the thinking of Aristotle legitimate in
other words a captive is someone who can
be killed or not killed with without the
slightest bit of conscience and the
minds of of the killer and all and that
point also relates to the issue of
slavery where you can kill someone or
have them work for you until they die
and it's it's sort of a matter of
indifference which it is and people are
very understandably very strong feelings
today about the various ways in which
killing occurs in scholarship this has
led to a to a repeated effort in
different parts of the world by scholars
to deny that there ever was any human
sacrifice and the particular culture
that they're interested in they don't
like to think about human sacrifice and
then some curmudgeon comes along and
says yes but here's a text that shows
you that there was
human sacrifice so generally whether it
is with the Egyptians or the ancient
people of Central Asia or China India
Middle East Mediterranean area you can
find some evidence of some degree of
human sacrifice although it usually
shows up as something that happened long
before the time of the source that
you're actually reading and therefore
you can say well it was superseded and
if you're a you know good old-fashioned
scholar you say it was superseded as
society became more humane and of course
this is you know you a society I suppose
can become more humane but I mean humane
just means human and they're always
humans and the question is is is humane
kind of a circular concept that if you
don't kill other humans you are humane
and if you do you are a humane but it's
not an abstract quality it is simply a
kind of a descriptive thing so when you
deal with the old world the tendency is
to deal with human sacrifice as
something that once existed and then and
then either became supplanted by animal
sacrifice or made metaphorical or
symbolic without a real taking of life
and all of this is associated with a
some kind of a rise of civilization
given this the attitude of the Europeans
towards what they found in the new world
is quite understandable in terms of
their thinking it to be Savage
and lurid and barbaric the whole notion
of the people the new world being
savages is colored by what the Spaniards
found in Mexico and elsewhere in terms
of large-scale sacrifice of humans so
that raised the question as to why you
had it in the new world whereas in the
old world you had had it but you no
longer did have it was this associated
with civilization well this was this is
a difficult concept because nobody
denied that there were the primary
defining characteristics of civilization
present among the Aztecs and other
peoples in Mexico and had earlier been
president among the Maya and as
president when the Incas so to to say
people were savages and yet they had the
civilization was somewhat contradictory
but that's the way things things
appeared to be and so the question was
why did you have if not human sacrifice
then the persistence of human sacrifice
in the new world
the
now I want to talk about colors now as a
indirect way of getting back at this
rent berlin and his colleague kay what's
his last name Jonathan Kaye perhaps
wrote a book called basic color terms
and they made a an observation that has
not held up completely in later
scholarly thinking but was very
influential at the time that was made
and remains intriguing they said that if
you have a language that only has two
color terms normally light and dark or
black and white that language will
normally pertain to a society at the
simplest level of social and political
and economic organization and that when
you find a language that has three color
terms which will be black and white and
either green or yellow then you will
find a step up in the complexity of the
society and when you find a language
that has four color terms which will be
black always black white green and
yellow then no I'm sorry red as the
third than green and yellow are the
fourth and fifth and blue is the sixth
and their argument was that the
complexity of color terms that show up
in languages on a global basis because
they're using very large databases of
ethnographies from around the world the
argument is that the acquisition of
color distinctions is mirrored by the
growth in complexity of the of the
society this was further compounded by a
observation that I'm not sure has held
up which is that the rate at which
whether the sequence at which newborn
infants achieve the ability to discern
color differences follows the same
pattern that the newborn can initially
perceive light and dark then black white
and red then black white red or green
then black white red and green then blue
and so on suggesting that the that there
is some sort of broad mirroring of human
you know infantile development and the
development of society as reflected in
the acquisition of color terms as I say
yet say the data have been modified to
some degree by later scholars but it was
a very influential observation because
it suggested that on a global basis
there might be ways in which you could
talk about you know degrees of social
political and economic organization or
societal organization that will where
you could extract elements of
commonality that so you could make
general statements as opposed to ones
that were just purely limited
ethnographic data
a an anthropologist named Catherine
Newman wrote a book called law and
civilization I believe it is that tried
to do the same thing with law less
successfully arguing that at the
simplest levels of law correspond to the
simplest levels of society and that
again you have a kind of devotion Airy
development among scientists societies
and that if you look globally at the
level of legal type thinking around the
world you'll find parallels that are
similar to those you find with basic
color terms as I say that book was not
terribly well received but it was I
mentioned it because it's an
illustration of of the type of influence
that the book basic color terms had in
suggesting that perhaps you could look
globally at a societal development now
what I want to look at globally is the
question of the development of sacrifice
the evidence for sacrifice of any kind
among hunting and gathering populations
is rather scarce you you're talking
about populations of 50 to 100 people
who have little or no property beyond
whatever bits and pieces of ornament and
utilitarian objects they can carry with
them not much evidence of a that they
did anything that was that could be
called a sacrifice how would you tell of
course you can find bones that will be
an association with ancient or
prehistoric remains but the Assumption
often is that the bones of sacrificial
victims will be in some way segregated
or made distinct from what is called a
kitchen mid and that is to say a garbage
pit where you just throw out the bones
from the animals that you're using for
food so you don't have very much
evidence of sacrifice it's a little
ambiguous because of the of the numerous
skulls that have been found that have
holes drilled in them process called
trepanation but it doesn't appear that
that was done sacrificially because many
of the holes that were scraped in skulls
showed signs of a wreath of growth of
new bone tissue over the scraped off the
area suggesting that the purpose of
scraping the hole in the skull was not
to kill the individual but to to do
something else
what I
I don't really know but there have been
various speculations of that refer you
to the book mow a Lowe's by Western
lebar for a theory on that but in any
case you don't know much evidence for
sacrifice most evidence for sacrifice
from prehistoric and early historic
periods relates to the sacrifice of
animals and specifically relates to
sacrifice of domestic animals so so wild
animals are seldom sacrificed this is
not universally the case particularly we
have indications that that bears were
sacrificed in a ritual fashion in among
the I know people of northern Japan it's
likely that there was reindeer sacrifice
although not entirely clear we don't
have remains that make it perfectly
clear but we know that there were horses
that were sacrificed and we have remains
of horses that have that were wearing
artificial antlers pretending to be
reindeer which was suggestive sometimes
a horse will do that those of you who
are a questions will recognize you
what stable there it is family after is
audience take that on but by large wild
animals aren't sacrificed much I'll give
you one exception at a moment so that
suggests that sacrifice arises or at
least animal sacrifice arises after or
perhaps in tandem with the appearance of
domestic animals which puts you in a
rough developmental date of the
Neolithic period and suggesting that
this is a developmental thing that
societies go from not sacrificing to
sacrificing and that the cutoff point is
you know with respect to animal
sacrifice is the period of domestication
so that raises the hypothesis that the
domestic that human sacrifice preceded
animal sacrifice and is superseded by
animal sacrifice that is to say that
people may have sacrificed humans and
then decided that they would prefer to
sacrifice animals in place of humans so
that the fragments of data relating to
very early human sacrifice in the old
world that come from ancient textual
sources in various languages those
fragments suggests that you had a
sacrifice of humans at one point and
then you move over to two animals my
personal inclination is to think that
there is some possibility that that is a
you know a plausible doctrine and that
the the emergence of domestic varieties
of animals may impart be a result of
seeking an alternative to human
sacrifice in other words of the process
of domestication may be more related to
the to the ritual killing of the animals
then to the simple economic issue of
subsistence but it is a it is complex
there's a story
chenna hosaka that shows up in the
earliest stratum of Indian religious
thinking and is almost a unique bit of
evidence for human sacrifice in ancient
India where animal sacrifice became the
norm so in this story there was a prince
he had you know he was born of a king
but the king was only able to sire a
child or his queen was only able to bear
a child by by the grace of the god Varna
well one of the great early
indo-european God so so Varna agrees
that this Prince can be can be conceived
and be born on the proviso that when he
is twenty years old he will become the
possession of Varna and he will die now
here we you know obviously we're dealing
here with a folk motif that you can find
in the story of Sleeping Beauty or
Rumplestiltskin or something like that
the idea of that you have a do a child
that is doomed to to face something a
terrible at some some point unless they
can be saved so the prince who becomes
aware that he is doomed at age of twenty
he goes out to see what he can do about
it and he wanders in the forest and in
the forest he comes into contact with a
Brahman who was living in the forest
Indian cultural tradition you have four
stages of life for the the sort of
normative man and in the third stage of
life you leave your home and family and
you wander in the forest and this
Brahman was in the forest but he had
three sons it wasn't that he had you
could you take your family to the force
you would leave a householder phase to
the forest phase he had three sons all
of whom had the same name or rather all
of them had names that meant the same
thing but use different words they were
synonymous names and all of the names
mean dog penis you know so you have
there are three sons who are all you can
see why don't like the story so you have
three sons named dog penis so the prince
this is presumably meant to show the the
humbleness of the status of this Brahmin
in the forest that he was not wealthy
that he was a lowly Brahmin but he was a
priest nevertheless so the the prince
prevailed upon him says to give him one
of his sons as a substitute sacrifice
and the mother he you know the Brahmin
agrees and then the the Prince says I
want this one and the mother says oh
that's my youngest no you can't take him
so I don't play so this one it says then
the father says no that's my oldest you
can't take him at this kind of
Goldilocks and the three dog penises
and so he put this over third the middle
son ends up being sacrificed and he is
then sacrificed for these desi in for
sacrifice and then saved at the last
minute by the god Indra and the prince
has been relieved of the curse that has
been put upon his birth by the god Varna
now this is the only evidence of a human
sacrifice that you have in the in the
Vedic corpus the record of the earliest
religious beliefs of the Indians a
corpus that goes back to the the middle
of the second millennium BC and comes
out of a society and Central Asia
originally but what makes it
particularly interesting is that it is
also a a singular example of the
sacrifice of dogs because one of the
conundrum of this business that animals
that are sacrificed our domestic animals
is that the earliest domestic animal the
dog is not commonly sacrificed it is
from time to time sacrificed so the
Spartans are said to have sacrificed
dogs to the God Ares and you do have
occasional mentions of dog sacrifice but
for example in the Hittite exam the
Hittite story I mentioned earlier where
you you cut a puppy in half and you
purify something by going between the
two halves there's also a pure foot
Hittite lore that says that no dog or
Pig shall be allowed into into a sacred
place and so the dog shows up as a
as an animal where it isn't sacrificed
to the gods so much as it is an animal
that is killed in other contexts that
are sacred contexts but nevertheless not
not quite a full human sacrifice and in
the case of the story of shinja sabha
it's a dog human being taking the place
of and instead of just an ordinary human
whether a dog being as human taking the
place of the of the the prince so the
earliest domestic animal does not get
sacrificed very much and when it is
killed in a ritual sense it doesn't seem
to have the the weight of the your
primary sacrificial animals which are
cattle sheep goats and depending on the
society pigs and to a in extraordinary
circumstances horses and roosters or
chickens particularly chickens that have
a black skin now say you pull the
feathers out you find the skin
underneath is black so there's a melanin
aspect there
racist attitude toward chickens now this
is an interesting thing you do get
donkeys I don't know leave out the
donkeys but animals that are
domesticated later than this set almost
never show up as sacrificial animals so
that water buffalo don't appear as
sacrificial animal to hump camels do not
appear as sacrificial animals yaks no
not in particular so you you get you
look at the array of animals and what
constitutes qualification for sacrifice
and you say well it's at a certain
period of development in the society
that the animal sacrifice comes into
being and if you have an animal that
enters into some sort of domestic
situation and becomes useful in the
society before that after that period it
doesn't get on the on the sacrifice list
so wild animals aren't on the sacrifice
list and late domesticus are not on a
sacrifice list so again you have a
suggestion a suggestion that you have a
an evolutionary thing in which societies
go through stages of complexity or
conceptualization of matters spiritual
that make it you know first no sacrifice
then sacrificing humans then sacrificing
domestic animals and then no longer
sacrifice candles but whether using
symbolic sacrifice yeah
yes that's right no maybe they probably
sacrifice children before they sacrifice
llamas right so so you probably have a
phasing out business
I mean we've actually excavated the
mummies of sacrificed children but in
small numbers they I mean they weren't
sacrificing the Aztecs were it wasn't a
wholesale occupation it's also not clear
how the Incan children died that say
they may have simply been abandoned and
exposed than the high Andes and died
that way stoned to the gills on coca and
other things people the they gave them
this this beer and got them drunk then
they gave them coca in these mummies
chemists have actually been able to
extract the the materials that were in
the stomach of the sacrificed child and
by analyzing the hair which has
different chemical composition depending
on when it is what is grown of what the
diet is they've actually been able to
reconstruct the diet of the sacrifice
children in the previous year and find
that you know these were children who
had lived on basically on potatoes on
most of their lives and then for about a
year they are fed on maize which is a
was comparatively a luxury food and on
meat apparently dried charkha dried a
llama meat and so it's thought they were
they were treated in a very special way
for a period of time and then they were
taken to a high place and
and we're done to death in some way
although the killing they don't bear the
marks of a of a slaughter but those are
among the the remains that have been
found very different from the
descriptions you could get with the
Spaniards of cutting out hearts on the
top of pyramids and things like that
now whether there had been earlier human
sacrifice on the Andes and what the
Incas had were a remnant I don't know
but you have sacrifice of baby llamas
down to the present day in Peru and you
can actually go on the internet and see
pictures of sacrifice baby llamas so
that the llama sacrifice continues while
the human sacrifice stopped with the
Incan period but but that of course
raises the crucial question you you
don't have that period in the Western
Hemisphere of a new set of animals
suitable for sacrifice you don't have a
set of domestic animals except the dog
but the dog was food but it wasn't you
know as an old old old domstica somehow
it never really achieved the spiritual
qualities of a of a sacrificial animal
perhaps you know some people would say
it's because dogs are omnivorous in the
garbage but then pigs are omnivorous to
eat garbage too and there are certainly
societies of sacrifice pigs so here you
had the Western Hemisphere you had no no
real sacrificial animal available except
in the in the Andes and that comes along
late and does get used for sacrifice
if sacrifice was a rationale for
domestication then you might think well
why didn't they go out and and
domesticate an animal and use it for
sacrifice but instead what they did was
they went out and make carrion wars to
collect captives not in particularly to
conquer territory and then using the
captives to sacrifice to the gods and
it's not clear why you don't you know it
it's clear that you did not have a group
of animals domestic animals that you
could substitute but why those animals
didn't come into into human use is
unclear except that this was primarily
in the tropical zone where the type of
herd animals that you would have had in
the temperate North or South temperate
zone were not available if they if you
think of them as being more easily
domesticated
all right so human sacrifice was there
it is not extraordinary in world
experience but it was certainly
extraordinary in the in the worldview of
the Europeans who reached the new world
and it left a produced a kind of
enduring image of the new world now you
did have to some degree equivalents that
occurred elsewhere but they arise not
out of the business of sacrificing to
please the gods so much as the tradition
of the funerary sacrifice where somebody
is killed along with a deceased leader
of some kind it is universally
recognized of the first gladiatorial
games in Roman history were funeral
games that they were combats that were
staged in in commemoration of the death
of someone and that whoever was killed
was honored by being killed within this
this funeral context the model for this
goes back to the Iliad again where you
have the funeral games that are held in
honor of Petro closed and you have
wrestling and other you know man demand
things but they're the primary game is
the chariot race and so chariot racing
you know the gladiatorial games which
are lethal and they're makan bat of man
against man but also man against animal
and this I think is a very early notion
but then you have the chariot race that
initially is funeral and becomes the
staple up until the beginning of
Christian era the staple of the of the
ritual use of of of a funeral situation
that becomes transformed into a public
entertainment and that is the segue to
the next topic I want to talk about
which is sports and what is the function
of sports it may or may not be so that
human sacrifice and animal sacrifice are
a common denominator if so I think
they're a denominator that reflect a
certain stage of societal development
and that that stage normally disappears
and is either forgotten about or
reinterpreted or transformed into
something symbolic such as the Roman
Catholic Mass or the use in say Hindu
ritual of ghee or instead of say
clarified butter instead of a blood
sacrifice or in China of the sacrifice
of grain rather than an animal's the
animal period becomes superseded it
survives in Islam but that is one of the
rare areas of survival of animal
sacrifice but the there is a question as
to whether among common denominators of
human activity weather sport is one of
them that's a very puzzling issue from
the play of world history
there are societies that have sports and
societies that don't if you were to link
sports and games then you might have
something that is more more of a common
denominator because there are certainly
societies that have games that do not
have sports ancient India for example
and then no sports but it had chess and
backgammon and even more games of chance
and that of course gets into the whole
issue of whether games are related to
chance or whether they're related to
entertainment we regard both sports and
games as being entertainments that may
be a fairly recent perception of things
to the degree that societies that did
not have sports had a substitute in the
form of hunting is something that can be
explored that is to say there are
societies where where the collective
hunt is organized and carried out in
quasi ritual conditions that are
reminiscent of a sport and also
suggestive of the possibility that that
sports are substitutes for huts
and that hunts are substitutes for
warfare in other words you have one
vector of thinking about sport that
takes off from the idea of games and
entertainment another vector that takes
off from from warfare and hunting it
could be argued that the types of skills
that sports exemplify are precisely the
skills that you need in warfare and
hunting you need strength quickness
agility tactical skill and a passion for
doing something to around object whether
it's a human head or whether it is a a
ball there have been something like
1,400 ball courts found in
archaeological context in the new world
that go back to the pre-columbian period
these ball courts are extremely
elaborate the balls are described as
being rubber and those that are you know
the the size will vary from different
descriptions and so on but it seems when
you hear read most commonly is that you
use the ball about the size of a
volleyball and it was solid rubber and
it weighed about eight pounds sort of
like playing ball with a watermelon a
small watermelon the ball as it is
described in the ball game
as its described by early European text
and as survives to some degree into the
European period the ball was was kept in
the air with by hitting it with your hip
your
or midsection it wasn't football
it wasn't handball it was belly ball and
the object of the game seems to be
totally to totally been lost on the
Spaniards who described it you know what
constituted winning what constituted
losing in a very late development of the
ball court the court the the late courts
have a rejection like that and it's
assumed that the ball was propelled
through that hole but that is not there
in the early ball corpse to go back all
the way to Olmec times and are picked up
from the Olmecs by the Mayas that was
they were going back to maybe a thousand
BC that's a very rough thousand and then
picked up by the Mexicans and seemed to
go as far north as the southern United
States into the American Southwest and
into southern Florida but this this goal
if that's what it is we don't know
exactly how the ball was to go through
there or what difference it made if it
did go through it's a little bit like
the ballgame in Battlestar Galactica and
that now is in in Caprica it seems to be
utterly poisonous but if it's portrayed
in both of those science fiction series
as being a defining characteristic of
civil of civil society the idea is that
you have to have a big a big assemblage
of people who are drawn to doing
something with the ball
now interestingly at least to me the
interest that the fixation on the ball
precludes a fixation on the circle or on
the wheel now if you see something that
is round and you're in the the old world
you figure that's a wheel because that's
what round things are there feels so
that the a chakra is the sort of early
indo-european concept of a wheel and it
shows up in various forms and
particularly in analogous and
metaphorical forums so you'll have say
the the change from one dynasty another
is a turn of the wheel an eternity of
the wheel or the wheel of the heavens or
the motion of heavenly bodies the Sun
the moon and so forth all get
conceptualized as wheels if you don't
have any feels those things get
conceptualized as balls you see a circle
in the new world and you say that's a
picture of a ball and so heavenly bodies
are more likely to be seen as spheres
than its wheels if you don't know what a
wheel is so that you know
raise the question as to what is the
symbolic role of the ball if you figure
that this sport has some sort of greater
significance and its point of origin
than it evolves by the time of the
Spanish conquest and it is focused on a
ball what was the ball in some Mayan
depictions the ball appears with a face
on it
and this is led and there's at least one
depiction that shows the captain of the
winning side holding the decapitated
head of the captain of losing side and
there's blood spurting out of his neck
and so forth that's led people say oh
well the ball game was part of the
sacrificial complex or it was and/or it
was a substitute for warfare but we
really don't know much about it it's
also clear that the farther north you go
the more likely it is that the ball was
hit by a stick or something in other
words occasionally in the Aztec Mayan
Mesoamerican context you'll see ball
players who were holding you know short
batons of some kind but once you get up
to Canada you have lacrosse and the
common element is that there's a ball
there we go there's a ball the biggest
settlement of the Mississippian Native
American culture in in North America at
Cahokia Illinois had a big ball court we
just don't know what was done on that
ball court but it doesn't appear to be
the same as the ball courts that you had
in Mesoamerica so it may be that there
is some deep significance to the ball or
it may not and when it comes to our own
sports what the significance of the ball
is is just really really hard to figure
out why in the world would anybody
actually play ball because you can yes
it's it's there so you play golf Howard
anyway so it's a mystery to me as to
whether the the sacrificial regime and
the game playing or sports regime are
linked or whether they are simply
parallel but they seem to be certainly
are reached their highest point in
Mesoamerica
although curiously the the biggest city
of before the Aztecs toti Khan didn't
have any ball courts so it's not a it's
not a simple relationship all right I
have thought of these two things I
wanted to talk about and then I thought
of the third thing so I want to switch
to the third thing now and that is what
in the world are we doing talking about
the new world if you should happen to
look at the chapter I've assigned for
this week on on the cultures of new
world you'll find that there's almost
nothing about the temperate zones now we
talked about the Incas we talked about
the Aztecs we talked about the Mayans we
talked about the civilized poor parts of
the of the old world of the new world
and when we got together as authors we
discussed this Lyman Johnson who wrote
the chapter teaches in North Carolina is
a specialist on on the Western
Hemisphere
he said basically he said how can I have
one chapter and cover two whole
continents how can I do it you know do I
have you know 25 words per proper people
and he said no it seems like the way to
do it is to put the weight of the
discussion on the on the the most
civilized the most developed areas and
yet there clearly there's a downside to
this that you you don't necessarily
represent very well what was actually
there and you don't know and you don't
make explicit the question of the
tropics versus the temperate zone which
I had focused on in the last lecture as
something that now to me in retrospect
should have been an important aspect of
what we were doing but the dilemma for
the author is it was very clear
compounding the dilemma was the
underlying concept in American world
history teaching of D centralizing D
centering the euro-american ie euro in
the United States tradition if you are
not going to have a lot about American
history because that's taught in a
different course then why should you
have a lot about the history of the
people whom the European settlers
encountered when they came to North
America so maybe if we're going to to
diminish the status of North America in
general maybe that diminishing which you
know can begin with having a minimal
reference to the pre European
populations in North America so that
when North America gets talked about in
the chapter
you got the Southwest and the missus
Mississippian or Hopewell cultures but
you don't get anything about the
Northern or Plains people's or the
native populations of Canada and you
don't get anything about the native
populations of Brazil the whole
Amazonian Amazon basin or the native
populations of the southern Triangle of
Argentina Paraguay and Chile
so the question of from the point of
view of world history what should be
included about the pre-columbian new
world at the beginning of this course I
raised a question of is it possible to
write a world history for for the whole
world now obviously if you know if you
are you know a Chippewa or you know a
Native American from some part that we
don't even take a glance at you can
easily say that a book of the sort
leaves out your tradition but there's
the broader question is that for the
people who actually live in North and
South America now what what do they what
do they either need or want to know
about the pre-columbian period and what
is the purpose of the narrative is the
purpose of the narrative - to instill a
notion of the greatness that once
existed so you'll feel like 30 cents now
or is it too
simply explained the tourist sites that
exist in your country and Belize or
Guatemala or Mexico is it to confer a
legitimacy upon that part of your of
your ethnic heritage that actually stems
from from inheritance from the from the
Native American population and certainly
later on in the book we speak a great
deal about mestizo populations and the
process of of mixing between Native
American populations European immigrant
populations of various sorts and and
African populations becomes a very
important theme later on know what
exactly is the is the function in a
world history book of talking about the
new world now what to me makes that an
interesting question is something that I
mentioned last time and that is the
tendency of world history books to speak
of the Western Hemisphere in isolation
it's very difficult to speak about the
Western Hemisphere in comparative terms
when you have no no real world
comparisons but in a more conceptual
comparison whether it is on issues of
sport or sacrifice or you know art or
architecture or something like that you
could do that but whether that would
satisfy the criteria of being a
reliable and closely argued history
narrative that that was the question so
we end up with a with a narrative that
severely under states the nature of
society in the North temperate zone in
the South temperate zone and in that
part of the tropics that lies east of
the Andes in modern times the argument
can be made that well these were just
not very numerous populations and that
therefore maybe just on the on the basis
of population size it's warranted not to
talk about them much but that of course
is U is something that I think it's
involved with the whole question of how
many people lived in the Western
Hemisphere prior to the coming of the
Europeans estimates that you can easily
run into in books articles and so forth
will differ by all will say at least an
order of magnitude let's say one person
will say well it looks like there were
about Oh 10 million or fewer Americans
people living in the Americas prior to
the Europeans coming and someone else
say that there were well over 100
million absolutely stunning differences
in in numbers the question of why the
population diminished so much isn't so
much a mystery I think it's generally
agreed now that diseases that came with
the Europeans were the primary cause of
the die-off of the native population
and that die-off is described in various
specific areas as being in the area of
90% and these by specific Gary's I mean
you'll have a description of a village
found by in a Spanish Spanish source
saying that 90% of the people of people
died what happens when 90% of the
population dies maybe it's 80% of
population or maybe less in some areas
the likelihood is that the farther away
from the tropics you got in the sparser
the population maybe the disease vector
was less was less intense maybe the
Inuit survived proportionally better
than the than people did in Guatemala
although Mayas are still around today
and other peoples we know that time are
still around there just in vastly
reduced numbers so were the North and
South temperate zones a sparsely
inhabited as we've come to think of them
in our American history talk about
Indian tribes well no because a city
like Tokyo and I had estimated to have a
population about 125,000 at its peak
that would have made it one of the
largest cities in the world let's say as
big as Nisha poor and you know what more
can you say about any city than to be as
big as Nisha or so so by you know we
look at the archaeology and we see one
world we look at the human remnants and
we see another sort of world and we talk
about
the the reduction in population when we
talk about the European arrival but we
don't so much stress the density of
population of that that you had before
that time it'll be obvious in this class
that I'm rather attracted to science
fiction there is a novel by Kim Stanley
Robinson called what days of rice and
something in which he says yeah
prophesizes how would the world have
been different if the black death of
1348 instead of carrying off a third of
the European population had carried off
90 plus percent of the European
population and he then writes a history
of the world a counterfactual history of
the world in which the development of
modernity occurs primarily in Islamic
and Buddhist and Western Hemisphere
domains rather than in the European
domain because after all by 1348
Europeans have gotten to the Western
Hemisphere yet and they don't get there
there just aren't many you know French
and Germans and English laughs crawling
around and the ruins of their of their
cathedrals the book is fundamentally a
failure in terms both of of being a
riveting read and a plausible
counterfactual history but the but the
premise as a so often true and good
science fiction the premise is arresting
because it it says that the
if you have a historical development
that arises from the burgeoning of a
population I've argued before in this
class as you know that that the late
medieval population growth of Europe in
my mind is a great trigger for change in
the world as a whole but if you have
things that arise from a burgeoning of a
population and others that are a
consequence of a catastrophic decline in
the population that clearly things could
have been different if the burgeoning
had been cut short or if the catastrophe
had never occurred so I think that when
we rewrite our history of the Western
Hemisphere in the pre-columbian period
that we probably need to be more more
aware of the knot of the singularity of
these societies but of the dynamism of
these societies their size their density
the intensity of their development in a
variety of ways and and look more
comparatively at this in a world context
and say circa 1400 how did Mexico
compare with China or the Middle East or
Europe instead of simply saying it is
something far away totally separate
isolated and we don't need to think
about it in a world context because
virtually every aspect of human
experience and human culture changes
once you look at it
in a global perspective it is not that
we don't have excellent historians who
do superb historical work on different
parts of the world but you just look at
things differently when you start to
think how does this work in a global
perspective as opposed to within the the
more restricted parameters that we have
allowed ourselves as scholars or authors
in a particular book or a particular
chapter of this doesn't mean that a book
can be know everything about everything
ideally that would be nice but you can't
do it you have to set those parameters
but you can set those parameters in a
transparent fashion where you explain
what the parameters are and why you're
adopting them or you can do it in an
opaque fashion where the reader simply
takes what is on the page as being what
there is that is being offered in this
particular Sportacus board so anyway I
think we really need to do work on new
world history in the context a new well
is a Western Hemisphere history in the
context of world history
as opposed to to continuing the
tradition of looking at as as a world
apart so next week I go back to the old
room